Wild Card
Weekend choose your match
up my stats are almost as good as Watts
this game is older than me rounds
Texas get over
here I'm getting hot at the right time
Steelers builds F press be all you want
I'm not blocking careless slide Packers
Cowboys f as a Packers QB I eventually
turn into a monster please enter
CD uh-oh Rams Lions BL eat kneecaps
Jersey
swap Eagle bucks tush push push tush
push stop spamming that oneing move
dolphin's cheeks locked enter friends
peacock
password can't perform so cold Texans
win beep beep is fun why won't you just
die this wait that was a playoff
game
Ro win here we go lion
win oh dear lord C away
go Eagles defeat themselves what a
meltdown spe
who this isn't the first time I've
frozen out my brother call
[Music]
Victory die die die by week means
unlimited screen
time and Flo's attack is coming back the
other way hug in Lions fans crying tears
of joy
sentimentality press a to chase Tomlin
out of the press conference Mike Mike
you got one year your contract Mike
Baker finish him serani Hur
who do you mean my Dad's here bye all
right see you in
Vegas